and that's my problem with socialism  everybody is so generous with other  people's money it's why when you look at  government housing or government  services it's never any good it's always  run down only when something is  privately owned do people have a direct  interest in preserving it maintaining it  and making sure that it's okay so when  we have socialism on a larger scale it  literally brings everybody down to the  lowest common denominator and that's how  they want us to live but of course those  are the top Oh They'll be flying their  private jets and you saw this with some  of the most prominent communist leaders  Fidel Castro Nicholas chaucescos Joseph  Stalin they always live like kings while  the rest of their society lived like  peasants